this is a production of Cornell
University there we go
welcome everyone to week four of our
lockdown here in New York State and in
the Northeast most of us are not really
talking about any release from this
until the 29th and so always like to
find a good picture I know not everybody
likes dogs at Turf but you know you just
can't help but looking at buck here and
thinking that boy it's it's going to be
okay
again as a member of Cornell University
and citizens of the United States of
America and people sitting around
listening to me I tweeted this out it's
at the editorial director for the New
York Times
I thought put something together that's
really important for all of us I try to
promote that that's one of the reasons
we're doing it is to get us all together
even if it's just to think about turf
that there's a greater situation going
on just to remind us of that while we
distract ourselves for the next 30
minutes or so if you'd like to read
about of some of the things we talked
about or you just can't watch a video
you'd rather do your morning
constitutional with a two pager
newsletter we've been writing it for 21
years the third issue is out if you'd
like it you can contact Carl about about
getting on the subscription list I urge
you to continue to check on updates that
are affecting us nationally at the state
level and at the local level and so you
have the GCS a nationally you've got the
Met superintendent's and GCS A&Y and
we'll be doing a symposium with them
next week but the Met G CSA has their
website here and a number of these links
are live and great to connect to for
things that are important for golf in
New York State and of course with the
metropolitan New York Bay Area being the
epicenter of the situation more critical
for everybody down there so let's take a
little walk through the time period in
the four weeks we've been doing this I
started doing this one last week so last
week on April 7th there were 13 states
that did not allow golf and now there's
15 states when we met last week on
Wednesday in New York New York a loud
golf and now a golf appears to be under
state order temporarily closed well one
of the things that's a reality of life
now as we're closed or if we're open and
still maintaining or even if we're
closing maintaining no matter what we're
having to manage the logistics of
Sanitation and keeping the staff safe
and and that takes time you've gotta
wear the touchpoints how is it working
are we cleaning it are we testing it are
we splitting shifts are we moving guys
around so if one guy gets it especially
in the New York metropolitan area where
a lot of crews are being impacted by
this you know obviously this takes time
to do so it's part of your standard
operating procedures now now big
shout-out to Zak Nick elude us who must
be a new green section agronomist in the
central region took over for my old pal
Bob fabric in the Midwest and he wrote
this article about what golfers should
expect from reduced golf course
maintenance and he really didn't
discriminate between whether you were
open or not open I pulled a couple of
quotes out of this like I did last week
I really like how Adam Miller and the
guys with the USGA are starting to
really come out and evolve the message
here right I think talking to golfers
and giving superintendents things they
can tell especially you're
discriminating golfers listen some of
your rank-and-file golfers just want to
get out there they'll be like okay we'll
give you a little time to get it into
shape let's depends on when we get
started right depends on how many guys
you lost is always going to be this sort
of thing we don't know right but if
you're out there and you're scheduling
things you know it's good to remind
golfers maybe they might see you out
there when they don't normally see it
because they're at reduced staff that's
got to be scattered and if they're
playing obviously it's even more
potential contact
now Jamie Robb is the golf course
superintendent at the marine Club out in
Vancouver British Columbia and he did a
tweet this past week
assuming created quite a bit of
discussion about being closed and what
he felt was opening the golf course
putting the staff at risk right so Jamie
came out pretty strong about this and I
think I'd encourage you to look at that
and see the thread that's going on there
just obviously many aspects to this but
in the end of the day what everybody end
of the day we're grown grass right yes I
maintain a Golf Course policy all the
other things about the things going on
but ultimately there's grass growing
there's plants growing there's sand is
everything if there's no play
theoretically you should have more time
even if sanitation takes a little bit of
time right here's my old pal mountain
estimate Nelson stuck in a bunker at
Pacific dudes well the parts of the
course that are really only maintained
for play or setting it up changing cups
setting tees emptying garbage and
bunkers I talked to a couple
superintendents the last few days
they're like yeah well I have half the
staff I have thirty percent of the staff
but I don't have to set the place up for
play so right now I can still prioritize
and keep the greens in halfway decent
shape and I can raise the height in
other places and maybe the detail work
isn't getting done right and maybe we're
not going to have that flower bed this
year right so so there's parts of the
way labor shaking out that's really
interesting and of course what's adding
to that in my opinion that's helping
everybody in the Northeast is the
weather is in a bit of a stall so let's
take a little launch through the weather
here this is from our forecast website
that we maintain throughout turfgrass
program this is the two in soil
temperatures on March 30th right you can
see we're barely in the 50s in the New
York metropolitan area and well into the
30s in upstate New York for much of it
right and then the scale changes a
little bit you see the 50s start to
creep in last week into the metropolitan
New York area and up the Hudson Valley
and you see but again a lot of New York
State still in the 30s and 40s and
here's this week this was Monday of this
week and you're barely in the 50s in
Central Jersey so again if Labor's tie
you know you're making decisions on
mowing growth regulators passes things
like that
soil temperature well let me commend
another resource to you right if this
isn't part of your library of resources
as a golf course superintendent I don't
know how you manage turf grass diseases
in the world to a certain extent this is
aia for all intents and purposes and is
the Bible of what I think we is the best
thinking we have about cultural and
chemical management of turf grass
diseases and if you looked at two of the
big ones in the spring that are related
to soil temperature the thing that's
critical to understand is it's not just
when the soil temperature gets to a
certain temperature it's that it
persists at that temperature right so
you want to be mindful of okay well I'm
at 55 I gotta go away whoa whoa let's
see right because then you see it also
determines you're going to need another
application if you've got a history of
this there's a couple of ways to go
fairways and rough well maybe it's time
I don't know it goes I don't know but if
you're gonna do it even your models
aren't saying you're there yet how about
what's coming for the week well let's
look back a couple of weeks at the
forecast for the previous week and you
can see we were in single-digit growing
degree days last week you could see
there were double digit growing degree
days but still not very many and this we
you can see the majority of the
Northeast at least for the next five
days it's going to have very low degree
day accumulation even in the metro New
York area so you know you're at a time
now where you can put policies and
practices into place because you're not
dedicating most of your staff to mowing
yet right don't rush out and start
mowing as soon as you get on a mowing
schedule right you're gonna wind up
having to keep it up so maybe a clean up
mow and and take it easy I'm talking to
guys even on Long Island that they're
not they're not that far along so let's
not rush it we still got all that
information we talked about at the very
beginning about plant growth regulators
right remind ourselves how much can
grass grow when the
average temperature is barely 50 degrees
right it can't grow very much now you
can warm it up cut it lower put dark
things on it put pigments on it but why
would you do that right now especially
if you don't have play now a wonderful
opportunity to promote our pal and
Cornell grad Doug sold that's
spreadsheet for monitoring clipping
volume that you can find at the
wisconsin-madison turfgrass program
website you can download it really
straightforward method of looking at the
various ways of trying to determine
volume maintain your 30% mow right mow
at 30 mow 30 don't take off more than
30% you know if you set your greens to
187 right the 30% lets you mold them
when they're 280 now we're gonna talk to
John in a minute about whether we think
we're gonna go that high but if we're
following the 1/3 rule and you start to
think about it in those terms you start
to see if that's what's you know keeps
growth at a minimum by following the 1/3
rule then and I raise my height
theoretically I should be able to go out
more frequently now let's wrap it up
before we start talking with John a
regular update on annual bluegrass
weeble Ben Ben McGraw said just the
other day western Pennsylvania is not
fully immerged expect peak early to mid
next week so so we're talking about
another week until we start to see adult
so if you're on an adult decide
application maybe it's time to keep
scouting and getting out there and I
think we should revisit this topic again
next week and talk more about it because
of places where a BW is a problem you're
making five and a half six applications
of insecticide a year to get this pest
under control so it's certainly worthy
of continued conversation back to Zack
and as we make our transition to the
conversation with John you know again
what a great job Jack did here with this
picture that he used in the front of the
article again commend this USGA article
to you a really nice progressive look at
sort of what's going on and how to talk
about it with golfers and all of us know
when the grass starts growing this is
exactly what's going to
and so he leaves us with a really nice
quote much like the other USGA article
did two really big shout out to
superintendents that have already begun
to adapt listen this is something we're
good at as a profession you're not a
good golf course superintendent if you
can't think on your feet if you can't
problem-solve
if you can't adapt the big issue is you
have to put a program a policy into
place
sometimes our operations are often a
little sloppy because you know we cut
corners and we've you know we put things
together with baling twine this is a
chance where you know that baling twine
ain't gonna work you're gonna have fewer
things to deal with and you're gonna
have to be more strategic about how you
use those resources and so let's start
with ultimately again the mowing
discussion and in that article zack
talks about the role that role rolling
place and you know John's done a lot of
work in this area
managing bank grass greens in the
transition zone where to reduce stress
John if I've got the discussion right to
reduce stress you're recommending you
know skipping mowing and rolling and and
and obviously by reducing stress not
only do you keep them alive but you know
maybe you need less fungicides maybe you
need less water maybe you need less
nitrogen I don't want to presume to know
the Cascade of benefits but because
they're clear and you and I have talked
about them on you know the frankly
speaking podcast and you've been around
and published on these things but here's
the questions for the culvert situation
right a lot of people are raising their
Heights are cutting a lot of guys are
gonna go to be honest going to 130 it's
raising the height of cut in many are
many golf courses nowadays going a 150
or 180 is is becoming popular if we're
raising the height of cut John and I can
get across the golf course faster with a
roller than I can with mowing should I
do it for less stress definitely
definitely we've you know we've been
doing that since 2002 2003 you're
looking at it and for multiple years so
we've got almost 18 years of data
looking at it and you know we've done
all sorts of mowing Heights from
at point-o 802 1/10 of an inch
to 115 125 I'm the highest we've done is
540 seconds of an inch so 156 but you
know going from 125 to 150 six week an
eighth of an inch to five forty seconds
of an inch and mowing daily at an eighth
of an inch and using that is the kind of
the standard so that's what are your
speeds when you mow at an eighth of an
inch we can alternate mowing and rolling
at five thirty seconds of an inch with
one of these speed rollers whether it's
a EMI or a true surface or a true turf
and we can actually increase the speeds
by about four to six inches by raising
the mowing height but you know four six
inches you know when you look at the
it's not realistically you know study
done at Michigan State by Karcher and
Nikolai showed that a golfer can't tell
that difference but if we roll daily and
we mow three times a week we can
actually increase the green speed at
five thirty seconds of an inch by a foot
and a half over an eighth of an inch and
then going back to what you're saying is
this stress and reducing the number of
the times that it takes the mow and I
look at it as whether it's a shade
stress or a heat stress or whatever the
stress is if you're as long as you're
not exceeding that one-third rule by
mowing so maybe maybe you need to use a
plant growth regular when it's actively
growing you know you you're wound in
that plant when you cut it so if it's
heat stress or if it's shade stress and
that plant can't produce enough
carbohydrates it takes energy to heal
that wound so if you're reducing that
cutting that in half is that the ability
of that plant - you know photosynthate
and accumulate carbohydrates it's gonna
be a lot better
it's that skippy perfect so does is it
possible to use rolling then to reduce
overall maintenance not just mowing so
in addition to maintaining the
performance right I mean you're
maintaining the performance you're not
cutting as much and now you know you see
minimal maintenance programs John that
are saying twice a week three times a
week so if we don't want to violate the
one third
I'm sure in your neck of the woods where
we're gonna be in another month they
have to use growth regulators if they're
gonna mow that infrequently yes yes
definitely because our we're in the
conditions where now girls is perfect
for been grass you know our daytime and
nighttime temperatures are you know at
that 50 percent or whatever we're at
peak growth right now and yeah so the
primo applications or the new
applications are going out to control
that um and they can still be alternate
they're not mowing every day some of the
clubs now this is specific for Benton
polo greens I wouldn't do this for
Bermuda greens you would not occurs
we're talking about Benton polo greens
right so that Impala greens do you think
is it reasonable now that you're in that
perfect Bank grass growing period it's
not too hot then even the poet was
crapping out so some of the PO is
probably still doing okay where you are
if you let's say you went five thirty
seconds 157 right and you're using a
growth regulator and you the one-third
rule takes you almost to 180 I got a
believe it takes you to over 180 Costa
close to point two right I can do that
and roll and see to me I want to roll
fast and I'm trying to save as much time
triplex mowing some guys aren't putting
buckets on you seeing guys not putting
buckets up no we're always putting
buckets on greens for sure and cuz
they're playing yeah because they're
playing yeah because we're playing I
think you have the time-saving and the
money savings is huge we did an economic
impact of that in it and it showed
including the cost of buying the rollers
if you're a golf course that could
publicly
it's gonna cost you an extra eighty
dollars a year if you do this
alternating mowing and rolling practice
to him and you know it's gonna cost you
an extra eighty dollars a year to
purchase that mode so it in here oh oh
you're a general yeah eighty dollars
that includes purchasing the rollers now
if you're a on the other end of that
spectrum is if you're a private golf
club in Tennessee could we broke it down
for public private and
you know triplex versus walk Moe if
you're because they pay different in
some of the things for their people that
work on the greens you know you get paid
more at a private club on clubs that wok
milk rub walk more greens you have
bigger budgets and they can afford to
hire you know their hourly workers right
that's right
so if you're an 18-hole golf facility
that wok mows greens in Tennessee and
you alternate mowing and rolling through
the season on your Bank grass you can
save as much as twenty two thousand
dollars a year now this is all data from
this oh six oh seven twenty two thousand
dollars a year on your budget
okay this cut is so much faster to go
out and enroll the Greens with two speed
rollers than it is to have the average
of five people walk mowing greens okay
so what about now that most of a band
didn't walk mowing and have got the
triplex you've done some economics of
tripe lexingto right yeah so they still
save money they're still saving money on
that as well on the private club level
they're still saving I can't remember
that the numbers are on that but it's
into the thousands because a lot of guys
are moving to some of the newer
triplexes there's a number of them on
the market that that are giving other
than the stripe giving a hand mole
quality caught at least that's what I
hear you see the cutting units are
getting aggressive again on the on these
units so my question is if I you know we
don't have clay so I'm gonna ask you to
speculate a little okay we don't have
play and you saw the whether we're in a
stall if you had to plan you know you
I'm giving you hindsight right you know
what you know now and it's about to be
here in a month
what would you plan to do if you knew
you had half to a third of the staff you
normally did and you didn't really want
to skimp on your greens but even just
two guys mowing 18 greens or 27 greens
or 19 Greets whatever it takes a lot of
time and I don't know how long this is
gonna go so what would you say yeah
that's that's a good question cuz you
know before you came on Carl and I were
talking we have an email thread that
goes around because for the people that
have Bermuda greens here in Tennessee
and we're actually getting down to a
frost and people are like are you
covering your greens or you not and one
of the comments was this person
it came out of Bowling Green Kentucky a
superintendent saying I'm not covering
because I want to set back because we
were in the 80s last week um so the
Bermuda is up and going he goes we're
not allowed to play golf so I want to
shock my bermudagrass so it stops and
slows down growing so we we can cut that
maintenance practice yeah
like anything we're doing at budgets are
being cut you know don't put your
pre-emerge on your rough this year
because you everything's being cut but
focus on your greens you know dedicate
the greens but my mentality my thought
philosophy is whether you're in a budget
crisis or weather crisis you know
rolling is more important on been grass
greens as it is mowing and I think
you're mowing free rolling frequency
should be more than you're mowing
frequencies any time of the year and
that's just my take that's that's a
perfect way to segment two questions
Carl we get any questions yeah so so
dave is asking a question basically to
that effect John he's saying for courses
that aren't open for play and already
have these restrictions and staff maybe
they can only know three to four times a
week as it is is there a better benefit
to adding rolling essentially I'm only
going to be able to cut three in three
times a week if there's something that
rolling is gonna get me you know those
other three or four days a week
definitely it's gonna get you more speed
more trueness and more consistency and
and and if you can do it if you can roll
a minimum of three times a week you know
during dollar spot pressure
I mean studies year-after-year showing
it cuts that down by four fifty to
eighty percent the right for Julie what
was so what about no play no play would
if he's small in three times a week
could he go to once or twice a week and
just roll see that's a good question I
would you know you
but if there's no play at all yeah I
would still want to get those Rowling's
in just to keep the you know the disease
pressure down because you know some of
that you're you know you can reduce your
fun your size applications and maybe not
have to do like the chlorothalonil but
maybe just it was cheaper systemics or
something you know those are some of the
things I would I would consider and I
don't know about two times a week but
you know three times you know
alternating mowing and rolling yeah you
could do it Monday Wednesday Friday and
if it's cool enough you could only maybe
get away with two mowings a week I don't
know right now we are right now we are
not sure I would I wouldn't know Monday
Wednesday Friday and INMO to say and
Thursday if your course is not open
that's just like in cool cool climates
for sure if you're not getting the
growth so I had a question John we were
talking about and Frank was mentioning
earlier with some Bowers and the strike
being and the aggressiveness of Scott I
know you've done some research over the
years on how you set them over up and
how that affects maybe the height of cut
versus bench height and quality of cut
is there anything people should be
thinking about right now especially
without playing restrictions and how
they're gonna set the mower up not too
much it's just more of the mowing height
and I mean a lot of people when that
when they're getting into that craze of
lowering mowing Heights we're adjusting
the behind Center distance and getting a
lower effective high to cut you know we
did Studies on that and just shows that
the more aggressive you're spending that
real before you actually cut that blade
it's like a jab jab jab punch instead of
a jab jab punch you're picking up more
sand you're not really getting more
clickings
but you're you're causing more stress so
that the factory settings basically you
know the engineers have figured it out
so the factory settings are we should
keep your my opinion your your behind
senator distances for sure also to talk
about the triplex you know the people
that are truck the new triplex mowers
you know are they cut just as good as
the walking mowers the challenge is is
at the private clubs and they see
someone triplex seen versus walking the
members think what are you doing cutting
corners you know so it's an education
thing um and it's also you got to make
sure you have to turn around the places
that you know that's one
challenges why people like the walking
pedestrian mower is you know they could
put a lattice down spin on if there's a
bunker close to them what what about
what about I thought I remember you and
Tom doing a study looking at the speed
roller versus two triplex base roller
right because if if I've got a triplex
base roller and a triplex that I'm
mowing with and and I just play games
back and forth do I even without play
there's a part of me that's convinced if
I don't wound that plant Rowling's
better than mowing if it's not growing
very much and I don't have to wound it
for any reason rolling is a way to just
sort of keep things smooth and
neutralized
even if nobody's on them I mean that's
sort of the general way I'm thinking
about it is that a good way to think
about it that's a great way to think
about it and then what about triplex
rollers triplex rollers are great you
know you know you don't have to buy
another piece of equipment but it's you
know it's time to swap it back and forth
but you know it's not that much time so
those are great and they also have come
with the ones that have the vibratory
rollers which we found are really
effective at helping incorporates and
topdressing after you've brushed so
rolling after topdressing
after you brush it in helps but the
vibratory run really helps shake it down
deeper Carl have more questions yeah
John Melvin scenes got a really good
question he's asking about reducing
disease pressure rolling versus just
removing do you do is there an advantage
to the rolling over just to deliverable
yeah and Paul giordano at Michigan State
I think did some work on that for his
PhD and he showed that it had a greater
benefit by rolling than just go in and
do with being alone you know because one
is to do it Benny are you removing the
goo tation water but there's he found
something microbe illegally that's
happening at the crown that helped
reduce that disease so yes I would the
rolling is definitely a better you know
they're both good practices but the
rolling is definitely going to reduce
your disease by a lot it appears from
Paul's work that that the compression up
at the top is altering he's speculating
that it's altering moisture content it's
keeping
more uniform in a way that is either
suppressing the existing pathogen or
enhancing antagonizing plant defenses or
other microbes is definitely something
weird going on but it's not just for
dollar spot it's pink snow it's microd
opium patch it's it's moss in some ways
there's been you know I've showed in
high cut turf you walk you know you ride
on it you don't get crabgrass in it so
you know I've always argued that there's
something about the imposition and of
that force right its triggering the
plant to defend itself but that doesn't
seem as bad as mowing it way like you
say you're physiologically creating a
wound which has a different cascade of
defense mechanisms then then maybe just
being slightly completely compressed
right I think it'd be interesting to
analyze plants after rolling and stuff
to things like we do for nutrition for
secondary metabolites that way it and
kale and those types of come up those
things being triggered when you when you
do that and you know defense mechanisms
of the point that's right Carl questions
before we get John out of here just one
last question
rich is asking since we have John here
he was thinking probably about soil
physical properties he's asking about
the inner QG versus something like the
Berta drain with a kick action do you
have any experience with that John and
what do you think about that you know
we've done a lot of work years ago with
the air 2g2 and what we've haven't
compared it to the verted rain with the
kick action side-by-side but we did find
with the with the verdict with the air
2g2 is it actually immediately after
doing it it increased green speeds I
almost looked like it was like waving
like a bedsheet it picks up and then it
settles it down but in very poorly
drained areas it increased our in
filtration drainage rates by about
twenty to forty percent but it's very
short-lived it doesn't it's gone after a
week but you know if you've got you know
we just had four inches of rain the
other day that would have been a good
time to go out and some of the high
drained areas to get him to drain fast
or at the air 2g2 where you couldn't
drive a
factor with diverted rain over it the
verted rains gonna impact more and do
more physical changes long-term with the
kick action especially I think you'll
see a longer-term benefit from that so
you think there's a longer-term benefit
from the kick of the verted rain then
there is even for what your data is
showing with the air - gee yeah so the n
- G - we haven't seen any any I guess
effects beyond a week after doing it it
kind of seems to settle back in - the
air is just kind of compresses back down
or diverted rain you got multiple tines
going in and closer spacings and then if
they're kicking they're physically
altering that soil in a different manner
that the air is just kind of doing it
yeah but you know this is off the topic
and Carl since we got him I'm gonna bug
him about it last week we had raucous
Juan our sports turf discussion and we
were talking about cultivation around
these sorts of issues and you know one
of the things I like and we've started
to do is this targeted cultivation on a
golf course you're talking about walk on
walk off areas you know areas you know
you don't need to do the whole stoop of
fairway in this three places you can go
and this particular device
you said the guy out once a week to go
do these areas you know it becomes
feasible in some ways if there's five of
them it takes some you know a couple
hours to drag this thing around and even
if it's every couple of weeks right
if it gives you this alleviation
sometimes that's all grass needs is
it'll just a little bit of a leg up to
then get a little bit better especially
fighting a four-inch rate yeah exactly
and I think you know I people that have
have the air - gee - I said like in the
afternoon things start on 18 and have
your guy walk from our girl walk from 18
back to 210 and someone on nine and that
part where they go on and off the car
path all the time let's say well the
carts go off and it continually gets
compacted if you can keep doing that and
be preventative then that's that's a
good tool site-specific management like
you're saying perfect so Alton one last
question just came in here it's about
putting the baskets on the mower for
greens we you know we've talked a little
bit about taking them on leaving them
off and the positives and negatives
there
John you got anything to speculate I
guess early in the season maybe is a
little different in yeah the season I
guess I would just be cautious of the
organic matter build-up that's gonna
occur on that surface if it's a good
sand base green I mean I mean if they're
not growing very fast and you can get if
you can get get a green it's not that
much time to empty the buckets I don't
know I haven't had that be everyone out
be wary o of returning the clippings
because we're always battling you know
from santa dressing clarification that
reducing that organic matter
accumulation and just removing those
clippings is the key one of the key
three yeah I mean you know it's funny
that you say that because that takes me
down to Dan dinelli wormhole where he's
thinking about not wanda top dress and
he's talking about how this you know
just organic matter he's using buckets
to and this the plant senescence and
loses tissue all the time and generally
we think you know grass leaf blades
don't contribute as much to organic
matter but the volume of tissue that
gets laid down could lead to it over
time so you're arguing put the buckets
on don't create another problem and
focus on reducing growth by making sure
not much comes up and we've been talking
you know PG ours with Chrysler and sold
that the last several weeks so you
should be dialed in on how to do that
I'm assuming a lot of your guys to
Tennessee with that oh yeah definitely
in your right because there's very
little carbon in the leaves compared to
the the rhizomes or the stolons I guess
the stolons of the of the Bank grass or
they even the roots that are
accumulating so but you know any
anything you can be doing to dilute that
is key I think that's exactly right the
other thing is yeah the other thing is
just that we're mowing you know we're
waiting a little bit longer between
mowings now and the leaf blades actually
mowing off we're gonna be bigger they're
probably not gonna settle and it's gonna
be harder to break that down and get
them to work in yeah keep the growth
down rolling might have some help up
there's dog what's Doug saying that's
just just mentioning when you return
those clippings again you're adding a
night to get back in the system
simulating growth and you got more
growth to deal with so exact maybe a
little bit of a chase
hopefully nothing I'm serious I'm
serious
anyway we good Carl thanks everybody's
John thanks so much for joining us so
good thank you for that
I appreciate you wearing the UT orange
all right this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu